they're the pft top 100 free agents at
least the top 10. and at number four a
guy who was dominant for the chiefs in
super bowl 54 and really gutted it out
in the postseason to help be a
difference maker in the fc championship
game against the titans chris jones news
is that the chiefs will be using the
franchise tag on jones he appeared on
colin coward show yesterday had a chance
to react to the news and he said he has
mixed emotions i mean i think he
understands it from a business
perspective but his attitude also is
what else am i gonna do what else do you
want me to do
can i get
i got to get 30 sacks 35 sacks to show
you all what i can do so
look
the franchise tag as we talked about
earlier in the context of back press got
big cat it is a weapon for the teams to
keep players off the market and to pay
them less than what they would get if
they were able to go to the highest
bidder i understand why teams use it but
i think more and more players have
realized that it's a dance le'veon bell
showed us kirk cousins showed us
trumaine johnson showed us he's another
guy who played two years under the tag
and then struck it rich on the open
market with a contract he's yet to live
up to but once the team activates that
process all bets are off and when the
team uses its right
to apply the franchise tag the player
has all of his rights available and it
drives me crazy when the fans get upset
when a player reacts to being tagged
because this all started because the
team decided to deny a loyal and
productive player an opportunity to go
out and get paid fair market value
i i agree with everything you're saying
the only thing i would throw on top of
that is
what are the teams supposed to do when
they have that ability to franchise tag
someone so
right it's an imperfect system all
around i think players have every right
to sit out and say hey i'm worth this
much money i'm not going to play for one
year not guaranteed pass that year after
i've proven that i am an unbelievable
player and like you said loyal to the
team and then the team on the other side
if they have the ability to lock up a
guy for a year
and don't have to give him that
long-term deal because that's what the
system has in place they should use that
as well so i blame the entire thing i
the only thing i would say mike is it
would be nice if we had a new cba coming
up soon that we could get rid of it do
we have that
well but they won't get rid of it
because the concession the players would
have to make to take away that power by
the teams is more than the players
should because it doesn't affect enough
players although you could argue it
affects far more players and the players
who are restricted from hitting the open
market because the more great players
hit the open market the more that rubber
band gets stretched the higher the
market goes and even if you don't become
the highest paid player your position
you get a lot closer to the highest paid
player and that highest paid player is
making a lot more here's the thing that
bothers me the teams do have the right
to do it and i'm not saying they're in
the wrong i'm not saying they should
sacrifice that that ability to use the
franchise tag but when the teams do it
nobody says boo but when the player says
i don't like it he's greedy when the
player exercises his right in response
to the franchise tag chess match he's
being unreasonable he's not a team
player he's being selfish why don't you
show up remember all the heat that they
were given le'veon bell when it when it
was coming from teammates in 2017 or
actually into 2018 the year he held out
into the season and and never showed up
at all like offensive linemen were
calling him out it's like guys the only
reason he's doing this is because the
team applied the franchise tag it's a
dance that the team started and it
astounds me when teammates when coaches
when fans don't understand it and i get
it that the fans don't but i i was blown
away that offensive lineman on the
pittsburgh steelers were calling out
le'veon bell for exercising the rights
that he has vested the moment the team
uses the franchise tag well we don't
know if that was all because the
franchise tag there could be a lot more
play there when they're calling someone
out because like you said you don't
usually see offensive lineman calling
out they called him out for not they
wanted him to show up
showing up but my point is there
probably was a little bit more to that
like there was
if they all got along all the time they
probably would have stayed out of it
because you don't see that happen very
often i agree with you that it is uh
unfortunate when fans call out players
for exercising their rights all i would
say
against that is that it has become it
has shifted over time and i think that
that line of thinking is looked at as
antiquated and yes you will see fans
criticizing players who sit out when
they are franchise tagged but i also
think you will see people criticize fans
who criticize players so it's almost
there's a market correction going on
where a lot of people are realizing that
players are have every right to do this
and players should have every right to
do this and criticizing for that talking
about someone else's money is a crazy
thought so i think you do see this shift
and people are becoming more pro player
overall than pro team pro owner no i
spent so much time on twitter well you
know no the idea is you don't
you don't watch nba so
that that's where the shift is really
happening and i see it leaking in the
nfl more and more
well i hope it does i mean i i posted a
link to our story from this morning
about chris jones comments on colin
coward's show and immediately oh oh
what's he complaining about oh he's not
going to get oh this is you know and and
it's like look folks
why do we resent the ability of these
guys to get fair value for their
abilities and their sacrifices and the
risks they take every day why is that
so wait are you saying the pro football
talk comment section was not pro player
this is twitter this is twitter i'm
shocked this is oh well take that up
with your partner
he started it all born from the airs at
all
every day
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports